[Music]
it is Thursday right Thursday and that
means it's time for hell Bristol Palin's
boyfriend Levi Johnston in the news he
announced he's not gonna do any more
interviews huh
well that's why Levi said because I've
already used all the words I know hey
you guys all you guys all watch Jersey
Shore right yeah
get this this year the highest-paid male
reality star on television was the
Jersey Shore's the situation who made
five million dollars yeah let this be a
lesson kids stay out of school
[Applause]
you know what sucked back in 2010 and
beard beard glue
[Applause]
well Oprah Winfrey's talk show is coming
to an end yeah it's been revealed that a
30-second ad for the final episode of
Oprah's top show will cost 1 million
dollars yeah in other words the only
person who can afford to buy an ad on
Oprah's last show his Oprah 2010 great
time to be alive
[Applause]
I said 2010 he's sure a great time to be
alive isn't it Andy sure is
[Applause]
throwbackthursday mom wall screw this
I'm just be an Amish guy area the box is
ready soon children
you